we need scoop on fuller house we need it
now it's exciting you know I I just I
just watched a bunch of the episodes too
just because they think everybody's so
excited about it and I want to make sure
that you know they're happy with what
they're getting but it's so sweet it's
just you know we initially wanted to do
something different with it and try to I
said you know we all said no let's just
do what we do with the same creators
same directors same cache same set
highly raised on the feet what's right
yeah here I have it's fantastic I think
people will like it what's it what's
different about it it's a little updated
butch Walker is a great producer it's
got a little more edge to it sounds more
up-to-date yeah now you gave a very
candid interview with Howard Stern
afterwards any regrets about it or are
you like Sam fire
I stand by it yeah I was I wanted to sit
down with him and talk things out
anything I brought women
the 52 year old took home the award for
favorite actor in a new TV series at
Wednesday's People's Choice Awards
backstage Stamos was nothing but
grateful without the fans I'd be
flipping burgers at my dad's restaurant
that's that's why I was supposed to do I
supposed to be a restaurant tear to work
is that right you make fast food fat
food fast food restaurant so that was
cooked there and it was on jera hospital
I started our Hospital I have worked on
Sundays and he wouldn't let me quit but
I was on TV every week how is your life
different now
and you know in the last several months
it's great I'm clear I'm happy I'm even
you put yourself in the middle of
everything all day 100% now cuz you're
clear and you're focused and then at the
end of the day it's a good you can go to
Bengal I was there all day for all of it
and that's a good thing